women can be nurse but the biggest men
who make operation it's men women can
help and manage things but owner of
business that's men if you open Forbes
because I'm in big research in my life
and I have academic two higher education
psychology
clinical medical psychology Network in
hospital and I have experience about
this and yes I can say with absolutely
numbers if you're not new to you can
check on Google here's something clever
much stronger also try to check in the
tennis faster because they have in all
his biggest we can not we cannot this
lady in the red is you know the lady in
the red is actually nailing it I mean